PROFESSOR: Today, let's catch up
with what we were doing before.
And last time, we were talking
about hydrogen ionization.
And we went through
a whole discussion
of how it would happen.
It was ionized
because there would
be an electromagnetic wave
within the hydrogen atom.
The initial state was the ground
state of the hydrogen atom.
The final state
was a plane wave.
Our main work was computing
this matrix element,
and that's what
we did last time.
It took us some
work, because there
is a spatial integral here that
was quite complicated, given
the various directions
that are going on.
But that was our result.
Here is the formula.
And a few things
to notice here were
that there's an angle
theta that we recognized
as the angle between the
electric field polarization
and the momentum
of the electron.
So k is the momentum
of the electron,
and when k doesn't
have a narrow,
it's the magnitude of
the electron momentum.
As any k-- well, it's a little
bit of an exaggeration. h bar k
is a momentum.
But we understand when we
say that k's a momentum.
k times a, it has
no units, which
is appropriate of the
units of this quantity,
our units of energy.
And then another
quantity here, E naught,
is the magnitude of the electric
field defined by this formula,
with a 2 E naught here.
We discussed that the photon
had to have an energy that it
was not supposed
to be too big, so
that the wavelength
of the photon
would be smaller,
or much smaller
than the atom, in which
case the spatial dependence
of the electromagnetic
field would be relevant.
So for simplicity,
with took photons
not to be too energetic.
And we also took photons
to be energetic enough
that, when they would
ionize the atom,
the electron that would go
out would not be too affected
by the cooling potential, and
we could treat it like a plane
wave to a good approximation--
a free plane wave.
Otherwise, you would have to
use more complicated plane
waves associated
with a hydrogen atom.
So under this
ranges, these ranges
translate to this ranges for
the momentum of the electron.
And if the-- as required,
the energy of the photon
is significantly bigger than a
Rydberg, which is the 13.6 eV.
This is like 10
Rydbergs in here.
Then the momentum
of the electron
is given by this formula
to a good approximation.
It's essentially the
energy of the photon, then
the square root of that.
The last ingredient
in our computation
is the density of states.
This was calculated also
a couple of weeks ago,
so you have to keep track
of some formulas here.
There's some formulas that
they're a little complicated,
but we'll have to box them
and just be ready to use them,
or to spend five minutes
really writing them.
And this was the
formula for the density
of states with some energy
E. With that energy E,
these were free
plane wave states.
Energy E, momentum k associated
with E, and being shot
into some solid angle in space.
And this is the solid angle.
So I wrote it as a
solid angle in here.
So this is basically where
we stood and, at this moment,
we want to complete
the discussion
and get a simple expression,
and simplify it, and get what
we need to have for the ray.
So, if you remember,
Fermi's golden rule
expresses a rate
omega in terms of 2
pi over h bar, rho parenthesis
E, times Hfi squared.
So that's Fermi's golden rule.
And this is what
we want to apply.
Well, we've calculated
the matrix element.
This would be Hfi prime here.
That's what we have up there.
We have rho.
We have this quantity, 2 pi
over h bar is just a constant.
So we can simply plug
this here, square that.
There's lots of
h bars and things
that I don't think
you'll benefit
if I go through them
in front of your eyes.
So I'll write the answer.
But in writing the
answer, remember
this rho is a differential,
in some sense.
Some people might
put you in a d rho
here, because
there is a d omega.
So think of this,
when I substitute rho,
I have the d omega,
and I think of this
as the d w, a little rate.
So dw, d omega.
So I simply pass from
w to I called it dw,
and substituted the
rho here for d omega.
And here is what we get--
256 over pi, e E naught
a naught squared over
h bar, m a naught squared
over h bar squared,
k a naught cubed over 1
plus k a naught squared
to the 6th, and
cosine squared theta.
OK, it's still a
little complicated.
But it's mainly complicated
because of constants
that have been grouped
in the best possible way,
in my opinion, to make
it understandable.
This is an energy.
And this is an h bar.
This is actually a Rydberg
with a factor of 2.
So in a second, you
can see that this thing
has units of 1 over time.
There's also an
important factor here,
and that's an intuitively
interesting fact,
that the emission
of the electron
is preferentially
in the direction
that the electric
field is polarized.
There's a cosine squared theta.
There's no electrons
emitted orthogonally
to the electric field.
And that's kind of intuitive.
It's almost like the
electric field is shaking,
the electron, well,
it kicks it out.
OK, this is a differential rate.
So the total rate w is the
integral of this differential
rate over solid angle.
And for that, you need
to know that the integral
over solid angle of cosine
squared theta is 4 pi.
If you didn't have
the cosine squared,
you would have the 4 pi.
But usually cosine squared,
this is multiplied by 1/3.
You can do the calculation.
It just doesn't
take any real time.
But many people remember
this by thinking
of the sphere, or planet Earth.
Cosine squared theta is
large near the North Pole.
It's large near the South Pole.
That doesn't amount to much.
As opposed to sine
squared theta,
which is large all over
the big equatorial region.
So it's a little bigger, and
it turns out cosine squared,
the average over
the sphere is 1/3.
And sine squared, the average
over the sphere is 2/3.
Well, it's kind of not
a bad thing to know,
because it saves you a minute
or two from doing this integral.
And now, I'm also going to
apply something that basically--
you know, a formula sometimes
gives you more things
than you should really trust.
And I would say here, this 1
is not to be trusted basically,
because k a naught must
be significantly bigger
than this number probably
for this to be accurate.
So under most circumstances,
this 1 is not worth it.
In fact, if you
calculate this thing
using different approximations,
people sometimes
don't get this 1.
And you may see that in books.
So let's ignore this 1.
And then this answer is 512 over
3 e E naught a naught squared,
over h bar Rydberg, 1 over
k a naught to the 9th.
Pretty high power.
And the answer starts
to be reasonably simple.
This 9 arises because
of 12 minus 3 here.
This is still
probably not ideal,
if you want to play intuition
about what's going on,
and the scale of the effects.
You know, once you
have a formula,
and you've worked
so hard to get it--
this calculation is
doing it reliably
is a couple of hours of work--
and you might as
well manipulate it
and try to make it
look reasonably nice.
And this is what people
that do atomic physics
do with this rate.
So they write it in
the following way.
Again, a short calculation
to get this 256 over 3.
And they put in atomic
units, Ep over E star--
I will explain what
these numbers are--
squared, 1 over t star, 1
over k a naught to the 9th.
I think it's important to notice
as well that you could say, OK,
so how did the photon
energy, or photon frequency,
affect this result?
Well, actually, the
photon omega doesn't
seem to be anywhere here.
It has disappeared.
But it is implicit in
the electron momentum,
because basically the
momentum of the electron
is what is obtained from using
the energy of the photon.
It ionizes the electron,
liberates electron, and then
gives it some kinetic energy.
And, roughly, k equals like
the square root of omega.
So there is an omega
dependence here.
Now, what are these
other quantities?
These quantities are simple.
Ep is the peak electric field.
It's peak electric in the
wave that you've sent in.
So it's 2 E naught.
E star is the atomic
electric field.
And that's defined
as the electric field
that the proton creates
at the electron.
So it's equal to E
over a 0 squared.
That's the definition.
Or, if you want, in
terms of Rydbergs,
2 Rydbergs over E a naught,
and it's about 5.14 times 10
to the 11 volts per meter.
So it's a nice quantity.
It's in the land you're
comparing your electric field
from your laser to the typical
electric field in the atom.
And that ratio is meaningful.
And then t star is the
time the electron takes
to travel a distance a naught.
So it's a naught
over the velocity
of the electron, which is
roughly the fine structure
constant times c.
You remember the
electron roughly
has a beta parameter
equal to 1 over 137.
This is [INAUDIBLE]
alpha equal beta,
meaning the fine structure
constant in alpha
is the beta of the electron.
So this is t star.
And it's actually two
Rydbergs over h bar,
and it's 2.42 times 10
to the minus 17 seconds.
That's the time the electron,
which is not moving that fast,
takes to move a Bohr radius.
So this is the last
form we'll take.
Atomic physics
books would consider
that the best way to describe
the physics of the problem.
And this is really all we're
going to say about ionization.
It's kind of a precursor of
field theory calculations
you will do soon--
not in 806-- in which
you do reasonably
complicated calculations, matrix
elements, Feynman diagrams.
And, at the end of the day,
by the time you're all done,
the answer simplifies to
something rather reasonable,
and not complicated.